like you guys to write more songs
together she's amazing like super
talented songwriter finally Shawn Mendes
and Camila Cabello are working together
again the pair both shared that steamy
teaser to socials and it looks like
collaboration number two is on the way
[Music]
they first teamed up back in 2015 on the
hit I know what you did last summer
[Music]
with this song it was so spontaneous
like we kind of just wrote it for the
sake of writing it not even I didn't
even think that it would be heard
anywhere or like be released anywhere so
when his label peaked out as a single I
was kind of like okay cool
but I think like I'm just you know it's
really it's a really cool thing that
happened but I don't think you can plan
those things I don't
Shana Camilla hinted the new song is a
follow up in these Instagram comments
and while we don't know when the new
track will be released
Camilla hinted on Twitter that it be
sooner than we think I've never worked
with the extra songwriter who I clicked
with as well as Camilla is hard at work
on her next album but she also has a
collab coming out with ed Sheeran and
cardi B I just feel really like
appreciative of being able to like live
and I feel like I just know what's
important in life
right now so I'm just I'm really happy
and I feel very I don't I feel like
really in touch with my emotions
[Applause]
you